I've collected all 6 Coach, we can finally retire.
Hmm now you gotta fill this one up.
Gridiorn Hights Intro
Guess who emerged from hiding!
We would've f****king won!
take care of him...
Sooo the Patriots keep winning
Despite My best Efforts
So to speed this along, we are moving everyone
to New England!
No!
NO!
Yeah, we're not gonna be homeless, man! Ha Ha Ha Ha Ha
Say goodbye to Gridiron Heights...
Welcome to the Journeymen...
AHH FOOTBALLS OVER...
Sorry Witt...
Yeah you'll notice that might be, maybe I'm on fire.
FOOTBALL REALLY OVER...
l know it wasn't always great,
but we wanted to say goodbye.
Steely McBeam, who is it !?!
SHHHHH
NOW YOU GONNA WATCH BASKETBALL...
Thank you so much for keeping me.
I won't let you...OW!
Yes, we are confident we made the right choice.
WHOOOOOOOO...
Can you belive we're all ahem
Starters now?
Woah, we're men!
Yes I am a Man to
IM GONNA DO COMMERCIALS
G-men, excited for another year?
Odell? Guys?
I'm Kyler Murry
A little Football Baby
I can't be a mentor, I'm 38 years young.
(Bleacher Reports Gridiorn Hights Outro)
That's it. No more Gridiron til the fall, man.
So you can be with your family, man.
Or you can subscribe to this channel!
and spend 7 months watching film
We got 68 episodes of Gridiron Heights waiting to be watched
Watched Man
Next year starts today
He He I tell you what